Next, we'll do a little exercise
to practice using multitape
Turing machines.
Again, the point here is not so
that you can put
experienced programming multitape
Turing machines on your resume.
That is to get you familiar
with the model, so
that you can really convince yourself of
the Church-Turing thesis, and understand
how Turing machines can interpret their
own description in a later lesson.
With that in mind your task is to
build a two tape Turning machine that
decides the language consisting
of strings of the form x hash y,
where x and y are both binary
strings and x is a substring of y.
So for example,
the string 101 is a substring of 01010.
There it is as a substring right there.
But on the other hand,
001 is not a substring of this one.
Sure there's a zero here,
a zero here, and a one here, but
they aren't consecutive, so
it doesn't count as a substring.